hello everyone and welcome to a most
spectacular game that happened only
recently i was sent to me by david lala
so thank you for that it's truly an
amazing game and it could be definitely
a contender for our game of the year but
you guys as always we'll decide on that
it's a game between uh dutch
international master uh he is currently
uh 20 years old liam vrolic and
a spanish player currently age 16 jose
antonio garrido diaz and sorry about not
having a newer photo of him this is uh
from when he was 10 years old i believe
when he won the andalusian championship
but um it's the only one i could find
but as usual we are here for the moves
and this game does not disappoint when
it when it comes to moves so there will
be two i think pretty awesome positive
video moments that you guys will enjoy
let's dive straight into it and see what
happens it's from the semana santa
alicante tournament uh and well this is
uh not something you see every day uh so
relic with the white pieces opens with
d4 we have d5 by jose antonio c for e6
knight to c3 and c6 so we have the
semi-slop defense on the board
and while usually knight to f3 and e3
are the most popular ideas here uh liam
strikes in the center with e for right
away and this is all uh perfectly
perfectly fine all standard theory d
captures an e4 knight captures and
bishop to b4 check so here of course we
block this bishop to d2 queen capture
sandy for now attacking the knight here
and the queen is threatening to win the
knight with check but bishop captures
and b for again this is all well known
theory so both players are
of course still know this uh queen
captures on e4 uh delivering a check to
the king bishop to e2 and now capturing
on g2 would be very very tricky if you
capture on g2 then we play bishop f3 the
queen has to go back now we play knight
e2 then the rook comes to g1 and black
is not going to have a fun time playing
this so here as this is still familiar
territory knight to a6 we attack the
bishop here and bishop to d6 of course
we do not want to give up control of
this diagonal we do not want to allow
the black king to castle uh too too
easily so here queen captures on g2 now
this can be played and here comes the
move uh that uh well it will astonish
all of you so not bishop to f3 here it's
uh of course we could play this but
queen to d2 uh we sacrifice a full rook
and uh the the black queen uh can't even
dream about capturing this rook if you
capture the rook then okay not queen g5
as the e7 square is guarded by the
knight i know some of you guys were
thinking that but rather we castle
queenside here and now there is no
defense now bishop to f3 is the threat
uh of just winning the queen as the h2
pawn is guarded by the bishop but also
we can just move the dark square bishop
and checkmated the black king and there
is really nothing you can do here uh if
you play something like bishop to d7
then of course you permanent checkmate
but the bishop bishop to f3 just traps
the black queen and if you try to save
the black queen with something like
queen e4 then bishop e7 it's a game over
there's no defense against a queen to d8
with check so instead after queen to d2
we have knight to f6 again this is still
a known position
bishop to f3 now the queen has an escape
square queen to g6 and here we have
castle's queen side again you have this
problem of if the bishop moves how are
you stopping queen to d8 checkmate or
even bishop to d7 isn't all that all
that impressive here if you try
something like bishop to d7 then again
knight to e2 we're gonna play rook g1
we're gonna bring the knight to f4 we're
gonna attack this knight at some point
weaken the d7 square so
not a lot of fun so instead after
castling queen side we have e5 we have
to give up a little bit of material just
to free up this square for the light
square bishop and then the rook will be
guarding the d8 square so bishop
captures an e1 on e5 and the bishop to
e6 now and okay we've prevented
checkmate the rook now covers the d8
square and we've saved our queen so here
knight to e2 we're going to continue
development rook g1 i had a four all
very good ideas so queen to f5 now
getting the queen to a little bit of a
safer square with tempo as the bishop on
e5 is hanging
and now bishop to f4 and here you could
consider castling uh but black still
says no it's early for this and plays
queen to c5 with the idea of just
gobbling up the c for pawn as it's a
well a fairly important defender of the
of the white camp and uh interestingly
uh
you could uh
well you could just gobble it up right
away instead okay you could play
something like bishop captures on c4
but uh for some reason he he did not
enjoy this uh it seems that although
this is still a known position you can
give up the c4 pawn even the a2 pawn and
white will still have a very nice game
so okay he played queen to c5 he wanted
to bring his king queen to a more active
square now you are putting more pressure
here you are putting pressure on f2
and now comes knight to c3 again uh
giving up the c4 pawn and this is what
you should do here queen captures on c4
is still a known move in the position
but here instead of queen captures on c4
we have finally castle's king side and
it is now only as of move 16 that we
have a completely new game uh so let's
see how liam goes about this he plays
bishop to d6 now attacking the queen and
the rook and of course jose antonio uh
saw this and he was very happy to give
up the rookies now up to pawns and he
doesn't mind giving up the exchange to
alleviate the pressure a little bit but
liam is not interested in that he plays
rook to g1 and now you can see that
there is a whole lot of firepower aimed
towards that black king and how do you
how do you improve your position here
with black well at bishop to f5 it is
definitely the strongest move uh because
it prevents the white king from escaping
here it remains on the c file while also
you are preparing bishop back to g6 to
kind of gain more control over the the g
file but that's exactly what liam
doesn't allow here he plays rook
captures on g7 and now when you see it
of course you believe it it makes sense
the queen is coming to g5 rook is coming
to g1 bishop is coming to e5 how can
black ever defend this
uh well we have to capture it uh we have
king captures and g7 queen the g5 with
check bishop to g6 now luckily we have
this move and bishop to e5 now we're
just threatening to pick up the knight
with the queen and that's pretty much it
so queen to e6 is the only move that
saves the game for black we have to
defend the knight and now knight to e4
uh you could also consider kicking away
the queen with bishop to g4 but bishop
to g4 is uh
combined with knight a and knight's the
e4 the only difference is now uh you are
uh kind of uh leaving up the option of
queen gobbling up this um uh a2 pawn not
right away first there is one move that
has to be played and that is h6 so now
you're saying okay uh let's uh let's uh
just to trade everything off
but now white will have to capture on f6
so bishop captures an f6 with check king
to h7 and now queen to h4 with the very
elegant idea of knight g5 check this
will fork the king and the queen and
white wins the game so here queen
captures an a2 uh still it looks like
the white king is under attack as well
and how do you win this well the
automatic knight to g5 seems like it's
doing uh something but it's really not
after king the g8 and queen captures on
h6 it seems like you are gonna checkmate
black very easily but uh there's queen
b1 check there's bishop on g6
and now after king d2 rook ate the d8 we
try and give up the the rook but of
course white is not interested in that
white wants the checkmate the black king
king e3 rook after e8 to check king to
f4 and now finally queen to f5 with
check eliminates the bishop and all hope
for white from uh for delivering
checkmate or even uh winning the game
king g3 queen captures and now black is
just up too much material and winning so
instead after queen captures an a2 we
have bishop to g5 this is the good stuff
this is the move you have to find uh and
now uh comes the big question uh how do
you defend this well uh the only the the
only good idea is h5 however it was not
played in the game it's very very
difficult to calculate but i will show
it as you guys are demanding it so
knight to f6 check this is what we would
play king to h8 and now after bishop
captures on h5 it seems like black is
completely falling apart queen b1 check
king d2 and now rook eight to d8 with
check king e3 rook f38 check and now
after knight captures any it rook
captures uh bishop to e7 this is how we
uh prevent losing this with white but
now queenie for check and we force a
queen trade this is how we survive this
queen captures on e4 we're going to play
bishop characters on e4 and now after
some like rook to d7 guarding the bishop
here we would get this position where
it's still possible of course for white
to win this because okay for now black
is up upon but we are going to uh win at
least uh one pawn but most likely two
points on the queen side and the white
will have some chances of push pushing
this for a win however in the game after
bishop to g5 uh jose antonio did not
spot h5 he played queen to c4 with check
and now comes a question how do you play
this uh can you do something about the
position to maybe even win this with
white feel free to pause the video and
try to find the absolute best move for
white uh while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
beautiful beautiful idea and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is king to d2 and that's the good
stuff and here it works like a charm the
problem is if you go back with king to
b1 you just go under the mask of the
bishop and unlike the c5 everything just
piles up on that knight there is no way
to actually do something and even queen
captures an h6 checking to g8
bishop f6 again it seems like you are so
close to checkmating black but now comes
bishop captures an e4 with check bishop
captures queen captures with check and
now everything just completely falls
apart if king a1 queen a4 check we're
going to pick up the rook with check as
well queen captures only one with check
king a2 now queen d5 check king to b1
queenie for checking the a2 and finally
queen to h7 again we stopped checkmate
and we force uh
white to resign the game basically uh so
instead after queen to c for check king
the d2 was played congratulations to
everyone uh who spotted this uh and now
it just doesn't seem like uh there's a
good way to play this the d8 square
isn't really not a question anymore
because both the queen and the bishop
are guarding it so here we have queen to
be for check and now comes king the e3
incredibly now white completely blunders
the game uh the way to play this was
king to e2 but uh this game is so
complicated that uh that it's uh hard to
make sense of what's happening so king
e2 and h5 still is a resource for for
black however after uh king to e3 uh
there is now not all that much you can
do here now the point is uh but you have
to find the idea for black and that is
rook f2 e8 now you have completely piled
up on that knight and there is no way
for white to stop this after queen h6
king g8 uh you you really don't have all
that much to play if rook to d4
attacking the queen guarding the knight
to just queen to f8 there's no checkmate
happening you've defended and of course
now black will win this so but instead
after this mistake of playing king to e3
uh black counters with a mistake and
plays h5 uh
it was a useful move uh a while ago but
now uh it it's still a good move it's
not a bad move but it just allows white
to get back into the game bishop to e7
now attacking the rook and the queen and
even this is not a problem queen b3
check we have king to f4 and now comes a
queen to b5 and this is okay you are
adding a queen to help out with the
defense here of the of the black uh camp
however uh knight to c7 was the much
needed idea here uh after knight the c7
white will struggle immensely to uh to
do anything because uh well let's say
knight to f6 check we just play king to
h8 and now after knight captures on h5
we have a queen to c for check and this
is now uh well we're just gonna force a
queen trade king g3 queen captures here
we're gonna play king captures and not
finally rook f2e8 and the game continues
but black will always be better for
example rook to d7 defending the bishop
attacking the knight knight to d5 and
now let's say bishop captures and d5c
captures and now knight to f4
the game continues but black is always
slightly better however after king to f4
queen to b5 was played and now there is
no way back
from this moment uh feel free to pause
the video and try to find the the final
uh winning idea for liam while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not playing knight
to f6 we already said it's not knight to
f6 don't play that and for those of you
who were really able to do it
congratulations on spotting rook to d5
an amazing amazing idea
that finishes this already a spectacular
game now the queen no longer helps out
with the defense of the king side as you
can see and the problem is uh if you
counter with the queen then this fork
finally works we just fork the king and
the queen and we win the game
if you don't to do anything if you just
move the queen let's say queen to a4 you
pin the knight as well there's so much
stuff here on the fourth rank uh rook
captures an h5 a game over bishop
captures queen captures king j8 and now
of course is just a very very simple
checkmating pattern uh and uh
interestingly there's no way for black
to prolong the game here after sound
like rook j queen h5 will be checkmate
so instead after rook to d5 uh san
antonio is forced to capture the rook
with c captures on d5
but now comes bishop captures on h5 and
interestingly this is the only winning
move uh and it's not uh one that black
uh uh is happy to see because the bishop
captures an h5 again it's uh king jade
knight f6 check and that's it kg7 queen
to h7 is checkmate so instead after
bishop captures an h5 we have d captures
an e4 grabbing more material now the
queen is almost there the queen is
almost ready to defend the king side uh
but now the ship they do check and
that's just it uh so here king to g8
bishop captures on b5 we win black's
queen knight to c7 and now bishop to c4
we have knight to e8 trying to prevent
bishop to f6 but now comes queen to h6
with the threat of just queen captures
bishop here and regardless of what you
play here there is uh nothing you can do
there is no square for the bishop so
that you can't really stop this knight
the g7 was played uh we have bishop to
f6 now threatening checkmate and after
knight to h5 check we have king to g5
knight captures on f6 king captures on
f6 and he was in this position that jose
antonio garrido diaz uh resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here whatever black plays on the next
move uh liam will deliver this checkmate
queen to g7 checkmate and this is
definitely not something uh we see often
uh with a queen and king uh threatening
to checkmate the black king on the g7
square
so really a spectacular game there were
so many lines that we could have shown i
mean uh could have made this video last
like even a half an hour but i thought
you guys would appreciate it if we show
like most of them
and you know just just appreciate how
how well both of them played and uh it
was not a one-sided game uh san antonio
really had a chance to bounce back uh
but uh you know it takes we always say
it takes two to create a masterpiece and
here both of them chipped in a lot
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it thanks a lot for sending
me this brilliancy uh
uh so you can see how important it is to
always send me good games and use
hashtag suggestion in the comments if
you have a good suggestion uh i would
like to thank julie mosley uh chuke of
guzego arono and nagarjuna pony go to
dave ellis and pratam
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
and of course do comment does this
qualify for the best game of 2022
you soon